oh yeah i'm extra clammy
happy tuesday everyone it's another in
studio night here without a live
audience so if you don't hear any
laughter at home just pretend i'm
colbert
i kid steve
not really but everything is about
precautions these days you can't ever be
too safe one mask sure
two masks why not and while you're at it
put a coffee filter over your ass
especially if you're eric swalwell
a guy likes to fart doesn't hide it
i respect that of course while the
legacy media gives you grief even if you
register mild hesitancy over a vaccine
mandate
they still ignore some of the essential
truths about health that in a world
where you can't trust the media or the
government you can still trust yourself
you can control your own risk factors
and that's the good news about the
pandemic that the leading comorbidity
that influenced severity of disease is
one you can be and that's obesity
the bad news is you're living in a
country where you can get a cheesesteak
out of a vending machine
where your average exxon station has
more food than north and south korea
combined
there's a sunoco station near my
apartment that received four stars from
zagat
so it's really not our fault that we're
fat we're just awesome at making great
food and we can't stop eating it and
that makes covid worse
we knew that but in the media no one
ever wanted to say that this is the
media who regularly scolds you
like your 58 year old single aunt who
has the same haircut as newt gingrich
oh they bend over backwards to slam you
for your cloth mask but bend over
forward and do some sit-ups that's
unacceptable
in the early months of this epidemic a
few loud mouths like me mentioned this
would be a good time to lose weight
because it's a risk factor that you can
manipulate and we were accused of fat
shaming yeah something that used to be
known as good advice is now offensive by
people in the media who would later call
you a monster for not getting triple
vaxxed meanwhile they got coveted anyway
but when young patients died from covid
the websites wouldn't run a picture
which is perfectly fine privacy matters
but it hid an unspeakable truth
obesity influenced the outcome just as
obesity increases non-covered risk for
diabetes heart disease stroke sleep
apnea and also joint damage
relax cat not those joints
it's a drug reference
shocking i know
all right now according to the cdc 61 of
teens hospitalized for covet 19 had
severe obesity
and in general people who were
overweight are at much higher risk for
death and severe disease from covid new
study from the cdc took a look at young
people hospitalized for covid19 and
found that healthy young people continue
to evade the worst of the disease
meaning if you're young and healthy you
should be living your normal life which
means going to work having a beer with
friends sending me photos of you in
public bathrooms when you're drunk
those have really dropped off during the
pandemic and
i'm the victim here meanwhile another
study finds that dropping the weight
drops coved risk so instead of hiding
inside like you're joe biden you're
better off taking a brisk walk around
the block unless you live in chicago in
that case run
but this is a big untold story i'm told
because even an acknowledgment of weight
as a factor is seen as fat shaming
so then rather save a generation from a
debilitating self-created co-morbidity
we salute fashion magazines for letting
the plus size grace their covers or we
champion the clinically obese for being
body positive we actively chew out
something that has a that may be as bad
as smoking pretending it's a fun flirty
lifestyle choice
because this country is mentally and
emotionally softer than a tube sock full
of pudding
sounds good
heaven forbid our doctors point out the
obvious thing that could kill you
and what seems to be a problem oh doc
i've been having these terrible
headaches i don't know what's going on i
don't know if i'm drinking too much
coffee or not sleeping enough i mean i
also been hitting myself in the head
repeatedly with this wooden hammer i
found but
something's hold on what was that last
one oh i forgot to mention my wife and i
have been doing this pilates thing i
don't even understand no no no no um
the headaches you're getting are from
the hammer whoa okay first of all that
is hammer phobic the hammer has nothing
to do with my headaches and i'm offended
that you even brought it up are we in
the soviet union what is going on here
does the md stand for major
but really this is about health it's not
about appearance how attractive you feel
is up to you with obvious helpful input
from any construction workers
according to the welders on 49th and 6th
i'm knocking it out of the park
look the obesity epidemic has been a
threat to american health for decades
and a lot of it is our own government's
fault if the carb rich nutritional
pyramid of old was designed to shape all
of us like pyramids it worked
meanwhile we target people in peak
physical conditioning for making the
decision not to get faxed these are
people from pro athletes to navy seals
spent their entire lives focused on
physical fitness and yet an overweight
news anchor can pass judgment on them in
between inhaling ring dings and fun size
snickers
their most reliable source is grubhub
look before the pandemic i wait a lot
more than i do now
real picture
to be fair most of it was baby fat i
just love eating those babies
but when i looked at my risks i realized
i could do something so i stopped
mainlining sugar and started exercising
more bottom line covid stress tested our
country in every facet of our lives we
learned a lot about our physical and
mental health our limits but also about
how pointless it is to trust the
government instead you can trust
yourself and if there's anything we
should exploit it's the things that we
can control and that's diet and fitness
and in cat's case hygiene
yes let's welcome tonight's guests to
this roaring audience
yes his leather jacket says 80s cool but
his haircut says 70s bass player reason
editor at large nick gillespie
yeah
so cool
he sees more royalties than a party on
epstein's island
tv writer and producer rob long
audiences hang on his every word yes
they commit suicide to avoid listening
to him writer and comedian joe devito
[Applause]
and she's like the times square sidewalk
on new year's day
cold hard and caked with vomit
foxy's contributor cat tim
so this is day two rob and the no
audience gut belt show right yeah how do
you feel everything okay uh i think it's
it's good for me i'm not sure about you
why you think i'm falling apart uh
i think even when the audience isn't
here you still need to try yes
so you've noticed i've given up uh
those are your words i've just noticed
that um you're very comfortable yes yeah
if i don't have eyeballs on me i don't
care yeah you don't care it's like i
don't even like when i have the curtains
drawn you should see what i do are you
even there yeah i have no no who am i i
saw you in the green room and the first
thing i said to you was what i said you
dropped some weight yeah how much have
you lost i don't really know i mean like
i lost someone i gained here's here's
the truth i lost some
during the
initial covet thing just because i was
eating at home yes and then i gained
some back when we covered it was over
remember when it was over right yeah and
then then
and then i got covid in december 2020
og covered not the diet cove that
everybody's so proud of yeah the real
code right not the covered light or
whatever yeah omicron uh and then now
and then i get back to like uh you know
eating at home and eating normally right
yeah i mean you know well that's a great
story yeah thank you yeah i learned
nothing from that other than that you're
like a victim an eternal neck that's uh
that's pretty much it yes you got it
nick you're svelte
you're uh do you have any kind of like i
don't believe in goals i've uh it's old
scott adams line you have to have a
system in order to stay thin i bet you
have a system because you have never
changed your hair your jacket
your long sleek body tone
muscular my feelings towards you yes
which i keep hidden yeah no no no not
anymore i think amphetamines
are pretty much uh you know that comes
they every jacket i have that i just
reach in the pockets
do you think
do you think i mean this is an area
where you can shame the media
because if they
had actually reported the heightened
risk of obesity it might be a good thing
but they don't want to do it no and
neither did the government and yeah you
know that is one of the things that's
frustrating to me about all of the covet
stuff is it's taking whatever trust and
confidence was left in any of these
things down to zero and that's a bad
country to live in when you can't trust
the media when you can't trust the
government i think it's good not to
trust anybody
not even you know that's why you're in a
room alone without an audience that's
true
we're not even here greg just in your
head
if only that were true
joe i i marvel at the abundance of food
in america and the best measurement is
like when we were kids because you and i
are roughly the same age early 40s close
enough
when we used to go to a gas station
there was just a row of like snicker
bars and some mints yes
yeah
now like a convenience store
written large it's massive it's massive
it's like it's not our fault we are
fighting a war against our own abundance
we've been too successful and i think
the problem was when we stopped talking
about health and started talking about
wellness yes because wellness is you ask
well is it healthy and well
pretty much tells people keep doing
whatever it is you like to do which is
not really what the the foundation of
health health you know the human body is
designed to use food for fuel and to
move around and do stuff like that and
and they really took that away from us
they they kept mcdonald's open but they
closed the gyms they chased you out of
the park right because they want us to
be fat sick
unhealthy tired all these things because
when you surrender control of your body
that means the people who are in charge
get a little bit more control of what
they can tell you to do and how you can
feel and that is not good
it's like the the final scene of the
time machine right where they're just
all blobs being chased out of a park
like me
that brought back but for different
reasons yes you were chased out of the
park by yes by villagers it's very
it's hard to run away when you're
wearing a leash
connected to well anyway
cat you're a libertarian yes this is
like this should speak to you because
these are like a libertarian you you
want
you want to be able to control the
variables in your life without the
government intervening it isn't proper
health and nutrition the right way to go
i'm all about proper health and
nutrition
you don't even eat
sometimes yes yeah i do sometimes i mean
but also like when i had my second covid
yes i was only sick for 12 hours and
that's probably because i have the body
of a nine-year-old
so i didn't affect me that much but it's
not like there's this idea that it's fat
shaming to point out reality but it's
not shaming is saying like you're a
piece as a human being right like when
people talk about age shaming nobody
means if you say oh why are you looking
at me this 90 year old this 90 year old
is maybe closer to death than this 12
year old that's not shaming and it's the
same thing with this
you know the other thing though about
all of this is that when we're talking
about kids especially it's something
like 600 kids in america under the age
of 18 or 19 died of code
and somehow they are the ones paying all
of the costs including now being called
fatties yeah you know it's like it there
this is another thing that's hollowed
out any
trust or confidence that why have we
forced kids to pay for a disease you
know pay the biggest cause for a disease
that harms them the least
well even even the fat ones we have to
move on but we i could say that maybe
this is payback for the greatest
generation fighting the
nazis so those kids could be born
okay what are you really mad at i don't
know who are you really mad at i just
felt like
yelling are you mad
you need what doughnut yes thank you i
love sugar hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else